Sam bakeman freed was 19 years old about
19 years old about when this post was
posted in 2010 and I just want to read
this is going to be a little bit long
but it's really interesting I want to
read uh what this post says so it says
first off and this is a review of
someone using this drug
first off I'm a 19 year old male about
170 pounds who is experimenting with
nootropics out of curiosity a few months
ago I ordered a bottle with 60 doses of
5 milligrams of celeging celogenolene
from a research chemical site and it
looked and I've been taking it pretty
much every day the day I started taking
it I noticed a market increase in
motivation for me it was money there was
a huge desire for me to make as much
money as possible
foreign
what's going on we have an awesome
episode so we're going to start off by
talking a ton about controversy in fact
this entire episode it feels like it's
about controversy so the first part is
on FTX and we talk about the drugs that
they are on and it's kind of funny
actually uh how ridiculous it is the
second thing we talk about is the liver
King you guys have to hear the stories
about this yoked guy who's like this
Fitness influencer who's built this 100
million dollar company turns out he's
been on steroids the whole time but in
my opinion that's actually not the most
interesting part the most interesting
part is like these emails that we got
our hands on about him talking about how
he was going to get huge on Instagram
and he totally called this shot uh and
then we talk about buying and selling
high high uh really expensive real
estate we're talking like things that
are like 30 40 50 million dollars and
how this one woman Katie bought some
real estate that kind of sent some
signals to Sean and how he thinks it's a
little a little mysterious on how she
actually afforded that it's a really
really interesting story so check it out
I think you're gonna like this episode
all right we're live I have two
interesting things to bring up to you
and I think they're both pretty
hilarious hit me the first one
we talked about FTX we've talked about
Sam bakeman freed but something and and
then the next two segments I completely
ripped off a a YouTube channel called
more plates more dates so I don't want
to take credit for any of this something
that's interesting is that these guys
were doing drugs like like sometimes
they call them nootropics but they're
really just amphetamines or drugs and
they were talking about it publicly
where looking back it's just hilarious
how blatant this was and they just were
rubbing it in our face and so I I want
to talk about that do you know anything
about that with these folks uh so I know
what you're talking about I know that
they were kind of like
open about it promoting it but not uh
but you like like you said this wasn't
seen as too much of a red flag it was
sort of almost like oh man this is that
like ultra competitive nerd thing where
they're like basically you know I guess
doing Adderall and making all this money
you know so when you're making money
it's like not saying is as much of a bad
thing when you scam people and lose
everyone's money then it's like these
drugs are a problem all right so this
YouTube channel is called more plates
more dates it's the guy who breaks down
like what drugs different celebrities
are for different roles whatever and he
goes into in-depth analysis on it and
it's pretty nerdy but it's quite awesome
and he did this thing talking about uh
FTX and the drugs that uh Sam bakeman
freed was on and a few interesting
segments the first thing so basically
this whole FTX Saga it boils down to
like two interesting people so Sam
bankman freed who's like the leader and
then like his right-hand woman uh what's
her name Caroline Caroline Ellison I
believe so in April 5th 2021 here's
listen to this tweet that she she put
out nothing like regular amphetamine
used to make you appreciate how dumb a
lot of normal non-medicated human
experiences
and at the time she's running Alameda
research which has billions of dollars
under management and she's making huge
decisions and she tweets out the dumbest
thing this morning I was lying on the
couch reading a book then I decided to
go for a hike but it took me like half
an hour from the point to muster the
energy and motivation to actually get
from the couch I guess this means this
is when she wasn't on drugs and the hike
it was good my body had no problem
making the countless exertion of effort
involved in ascending and climbing this
whatever but the second dumbest thing
that I realized is that apparently
there's about a 20 of my brain that's
dedicated to food so when you're on
amphetamines you don't worry about food
and that she's just tweeting this in the
in the open you know this is like
this is she's just telling us all to go
[__] ourselves you know all the the
people like it's just it's that's
hilarious that that like looking back
that that was actually a thing that
she's just openly talking about this and
it's and it's wild and I actually said
that openly she had a Tumblr where she
said she wants to date a guy who's uh
like wants to conquer the world and
wants to dominate Global governments
like control governments control
governments and I thought that she's
like that's right that's what I'm into
it's so funny and so uh another
interesting thing is there's this
picture of SPF of Sam and he's sitting
at his computer and you see like a patch
on his arm and you see a rapper like a
uh like a like it looks like a food
rapper on his desk and people start
analyzing it and they realize that this
picture basically and this is actually
autism Capital my favorite uh my
favorite source of news they actually
tweeted this out and they go if you look
closely it's actually a stimulant patch
that uh Sam that Sam was wearing and
it's called Uh e-m-s-a-m which is
basically a drug normally used to treat
depression or Parkinson's but for
off-label use people use it for
alertness and focus benefits and so they
go down and they talk about it so emsa
em Sam that's the brand name drug but
it's really uh
what is it uh
lean I don't know seligaline I believe
is what it's called and it has fatal
effects if it's eaten with meat products
which is interesting because SPF was a
vegan so that kind of checks out and the
downsides of it are that it is linked to
impulse control disorders such as
pathological gambling and Hyper
sexuality which could lead to some of
the weird things that that Sam was doing
and here's what's even more interesting
in March of 2019 there was this uh like
website that was built for users of this
drug and in 2019 this person left a post
and it said uh where basically he was
reviewing his thing and at the time if
you do the math Sam bakeman freed was 19
years old about 19 years old about when
this post was posted in 2010 and I just
want to read this is going to be a
little bit long but it's really
interesting I want to read uh what this
post says so it says first off and this
is a review of someone using this drug
first off I'm a 19 year old male about
170 pounds who is experimenting with
nootropics out of curiosity a few months
ago I ordered a bottle with 60 doses of
5 milligrams of celeging celogenolene
from a researched chemical site and it
looked and I've been taking it pretty
much every day the day I started taking
it I noticed a marked increase in
motivation for me it was money there was
a huge desire for me to make as much
money as possible I'd never been a
material person at all although I had
money I never thought about doing
anything with it other than spending it
I guess some might say that and then the
arrow kind of screws me up on Twitter
but some might say that
um possessing a money is a bad thing but
the feeling was and is nothing short of
complete empowerment I love doing math
problems in my head involving money the
thinking was so clear from having a bit
under 500 in the bank to having over ten
thousand dollars in two months that I
had since I started taking the drug of
course I can't quite disclose how I made
this money but I have to say that I
engage in activities that I probably
wouldn't have without selling
uh and then I'll kind of like skim the
rest of the stuff but it says I was
motivated to use better vocabulary while
speaking to people I used to be pretty
goofy and not many people took me
seriously but now when I talk people
listen there's a notable increase in
strength in my voice and I would say I
probably had low confidence before
taking this and now the words that I say
instead of saying may I form it's I will
it makes it makes people tend to look it
makes me tend to look down on most
people but not in such a way that it
would affect friendships although a few
friends mentioned to me that I changed
because of my general mindset this
Probably sounds incredibly cocky but
it's true confidence I'm still nice to
people
it's just that I it's just now they seem
I just now that I look more confident
another benefit is emotional numbing
before taking this I would jump on any
chance to be with a decent looking girl
and I'd become attached pretty quickly
on it I'm completely rational and my
emotions my emotions are never affected
by my thinking I'm not even looking for
a girlfriend until one can rationally
show me that she's really worthy girls
love to play the game to say the least
I'm a calmer I'm calmer with a without
emotional outbursts when I get upset
with people I simply use my enhanced
Charisma to undermine them rather than
losing control
this is awesome
that's not the reaction I thought you're
gonna have it
like are you trying to take this right
now no my enhanced Charisma
increased desire for money
no patch with my first million in it
dude I uh I was prescribed Ritalin for
my like when I was in fourth grade and I
took it for one year and it was the
[__] worst since then I've never
taken any of this crap so I hate it I
hate these amphetamines
but this is a pretty good commercial
this is pretty great
this is pretty awesome it's also like
what if this is him what if this
actually is him
it's probably not him just by odds but
wait to assume that it is him and you
know as we say F this guy so so yeah
it's him as far as I'm concerned but but
even if it's not him this this person if
you go to the website by the way where
this forum it's like a nerdy form like I
it definitely like there's no evidence
but it adds up to where like I could I
could I could see that this could be him
um but even if it's not him the way this
person describes it makes a lot of sense
for how this guy behaved no excuses but
like this guy was crazy I feel like
these are gonna become excuses for his
behavior no I'm I'm there's no no
excuses this guy is a this guy is um he
did all of this under his own control
and volition and uh that's that's where
I that's where I stand well it's there's
no excuse because they just bragged
about it you know he tweeted it he
tweeted needed another thing where he
goes the best thing I do is take
stimulants in the morning and then
sleeping pills don't have to go to bed
I'll just round this out I didn't this
was another funny thing the uh that's
just it explains why this is not an
excuse the former co-chief executive of
Almeda he bought a boat shortly after
stepping down in August only months
before the trading firm collapsed and he
named his boat that he bought soaked my
decks
yeah
you can't write this uh stuff but did
you know like the you know one of like
the sort of most damning things about
how FTX collapsed I feel like this kind
of gets lost on the shuffle of there's a
whole bunch of details and it's kind of
overwhelming but one of the truly
unbelievable Parts is that they just
lost track of 8 billion dollars and he
called it poorly labeled Fiat accounts
and what this actually was
his explanation as far as I understand
is
at the beginning FTX when they launched
the exchange they're trying to move fast
kind of Scrappy startup thing they
didn't have their own bank account
and he was running Alameda before that
so they're like oh cool just send the
money to Alameda and then we'll we will
give you the credit in your FTX account
and they never trued it up they never
moved the money from the Alameda account
to the FTX account it just accrued in
the F in the Alameda account and then
they just used it to trade so the money
literally never even made it to the bank
account of the of the of the company
itself and that's what he meant when it
was like
people are like did you loan the user's
money did you did you do this against
the terms of service did you uh did you
lend us out or give this away to your
other company it's like no actually I
never even got it it went straight to
their bank account I never even realized
it uh we forgot to like connect the link
later and so eight billion dollars of
deposits just went straight to Alameda
and never even touched FTX and we were
just like it was just being like there's
no Market on the account yeah lazy
unorganized or fraudulent right like you
you take your pick you know pick pick
three as far as I'm concerned and so uh
that that I thought was crazy so you
know these stimulants aren't so
stimulating if you feel like forgot to
to like you know pick up the eight
billion dollars that you you know your
business is generating like if you get
beyond the fact that people are hurt
here which is a big deal but get beyond
that it's hilarious you're like it's
funny it's funny like this is like it
like just what's funny is how ridiculous
this is and and I fell for it too but uh
it it's wild this is a wild story I want
to see like um you ever seen the movie
Miss Congeniality where Sandra Bullock
goes from this like you know Butch cop
to like a beauty pageant Queen and they
like transform her I want to see the
version of that for FTX which is like
Sam is this normal looking that guy
they're like you know grow out your hair
he's like what do you mean it's gonna
look completely disheveled they're like
yes
disheveled equals genius and they're
like hey when you're walking turn your
knees in he's like ah it's a little
uncomfortable they're like you need to
walk like this okay and they're like hey
you need to put this patch on and
they're like hey um can you start saying
things like you know this is a 12 Sigma
event he's like what does that mean
they're like don't worry about what it
means it sounds provocative and so you
know they're training him to be this
like yeah by the way autistic hero uh
you know nerd that everybody's gonna
believe in he's the type of guy who
probably wears a backpack wherever he
goes and he doesn't walk he runs he's
that type of guy dude did you see the
clip of him running through the Bahamas
was he running
it's hilarious somebody found said
there's a clip posted on Twitter
um I'm sure your um your boys at autism
Capital have it on their feed but
basically it's like SPF on the run and
it's literally him wearing a backpack
running and he's doing the run where you
know like most people run like this you
put your hands behind your back he just
had straight arms and so he was just
swinging his straight arms
like a penguin running as fast as he
could just down the street and they're
like where is he going
that's crazy man this whole story is
crazy crazy crazy he came some more
stuff leaked yesterday or like he did it
he did a random interview with somebody
who's like you know a YouTuber with 10
000 subscribers he like decided to give
her the scoop and he's like um
she's like she goes so what you know she
addressed each of the concerns she's
like so you know when you guys reopened
withdrawals but only for the Bahamas
where people felt like maybe you know
the employees yourself included and
insiders could cash out and everybody
else was stuck and it was like 24 hours
where you guys you know people in the
Bahamas could withdraw nobody else what
was that about and
um
you know they're previously they had
said oh the Bahamas government ordered
us to do this that's what that's the
first lie he had told
um and then the Bahamas government came
out and said we didn't do that what are
you talking about so that was kind of
debunked and so then on this call he
just goes yeah um there was a decision
you know we had to make because you know
it's funny you don't want to be in a
country where everybody's angry at you
so we had to do that just you know
because FTX is based in the Bahamas if
we just didn't want to be in a country
where everybody was mad at us it's like
what this is literally you're saying
this out loud like that was your reason
for this that you didn't want to get
like beat up basically like how you
don't want to get your door kicked in by
the government how can you have Okay so
let's get Beyond like the crime now this
is the stage of a criminals period where
you're supposed to shut the [__] up you
don't talk you say I plead the fifth
where's my lawyer I don't talk I go
what's going on tour
he's going on tour he's speaking at a
New York Times uh Summit with Zuckerberg
and like oh you know these politicians I
think Mike Pence is speaking there he's
going on tour I think that's today by
the way I think he's he's yeah he's
going on tour and I don't think he has
any idea what he's trying to say because
uh none of it makes sense none of it
sounds good and both his parents are
lawyers incriminating himself more yeah
and then he tweets out this dumb stuff
where he's just tweeting like letters as
a joke
this guy is just what the hell you're
you shut up you don't say a word don't
say a word you shut up I hope he keeps
talking keep talking keep talking boy
yeah you keep talking I just want to
hear hear what you got to say let you
know go ahead build your own trap that's
fine it's crazy so I had to bring that
up and then another Scandal you wanna
can I give tell you one more interesting
Scandal this might be less interesting
but it's interesting nonetheless so we
talked about this guy named liver King a
while ago do you remember that
yeah the liver King the uh just for
those who don't know the ultimate meat
head this guy looks like a caveman he's
absolutely jacked and he's just like
always eating like raw you know kidneys
from a cow like he he's butchering and
eating it so he basically the back story
is this guy owns a company called
ancestral supplements or something like
that where it's all like liver and meat
organ supplements which I think that's
great I I I like the people who I like
follow they're like yeah that's like
fine that's a fine you're in the demo
let's just say yeah yeah like I I I
guess that's good for you Persona it was
called there you know like instead of
Joe Smith or Jane Doe they're like okay
so a sampar is online how are we gonna
talk to him how are we gonna get this
guy buy her like liver tablets so it
came out yesterday that basically this
was another more place more dates thing
that more plays more dates as YouTubers
name's Derek he got a hold of these
email exchanges back in forth with a
doctor that Brian Johnson who's the
liver King so basically this guy looks
huge he's yo she has millions of
followers and he makes a hundred million
dollars a year on supplements they have
these documents uh these emails back and
forth of Brian ex saying hey uh I'm
gonna get popular on social media in the
next month or two I need to look totally
shredded here's the steroids I currently
take I spend fifteen thousand dollars a
month and here what else should I be
taking
um and so spoiler alert he's on steroids
but that's not the interesting thing
he's on lots of steroids and the reason
this is a big deal is free for the past
year or two he's gone on podcasts and
he's explicitly said there's not a
chance I'm on steroids no I'm not on
steroids I only do this because I eat my
liver which you guys should buy too at
my website so that's shady but whatever
he's on steroids but here's what's
interesting I wanted to call out a
couple different things in the emails
that he wrote so he says let's dig right
in as it relates to my goal I'm the face
of several Brands including ancestral
supplements and I've hired a team to
build the liver King brand with the goal
of 1 million followers by 2022 I looked
it up
he had he wasn't even really he had zero
followers he had like single digit
thousand followers when he when he wrote
this in an email and he hit a million
followers before this number uh before
March 22.
impressive he says uh I've hired a film
crew who's living at my house and
they're filming uh they're filming
constantly and I got to stay in great
[__] shape year round
and what's interesting is that
he nailed it this guy totally called his
shot and he hit it and even though he's
a liar I respect that and so he
basically says that he goes um I live on
uh I live on a 15 Acres on the lake and
have everyone come to me my Ranch is 500
Acres of paradise I don't go out to eat
I don't go bowling I don't go to the
movies I stay home and people come to me
that was kind of interesting but here's
another funny thing that he wrote the
doctor asked him all these different
questions about like what foods he's
allergic to what is current uh daily
routine is what type of foods he's
eating and then he says what type of
food this is funny what type of food do
you like to eat that isn't bodybuilding
related none even when I eat sushi I
have a sushi chef come over and make it
exactly how I want it if I ever have ice
cream my my wife makes a lot colostrum
ice cream made out of first milk
colostrum I don't know what that is egg
yolks vanilla extract and a little maple
syrup and then listen to this he goes
you should come over and [__] some of
this [__] up with me Doc
and uh and then he says uh
the doctor says how's your mood uh as
you go deep in your diet can you
function and continue with your jobs and
deal with friends and family or does it
become increasingly difficult to
maintain your obligations you know
outside your body building goals listen
to this response I can do anything I'm
unequivocally strong in mind heart and
spirit and even though this guy's a liar
kind of dig it I gotta dig this attitude
let's get your moral code straight all
right guy proven liar
borderline scammer for lying about you
know what's causing his gains
um weirdo absolute weirdo absolute
weirdo it is daily routine he goes first
thing in the morning redeemed himself in
your eyes totally redeemed himself no
not not quite it's kind of like Lance
Armstrong cheated sued people for saying
he cheated ruined people's reputation
but was a real competitor real real
competitor
I guess gotta love the guy yeah so like
you know for us you're good in my book
you know people you know they're you
know my dad used to say no matter how
thin a pancake there's always two sides
to it and uh
so anyway kind of interesting that this
guy he says he's spinning by the way 15
000 a month on steroids that's got any
uh Eddie goes I'll spend whatever like I
need to get this done so I just think
it's interesting that he had a goal
he called his shot and he nailed it
that's kind of interesting was willing
to go all the way and all in and um did
it his way so you know there is there is
respect we do put respect on his name
even though he was a liar and scammer
um
that's that makes sense to me though I'm
like I'm with you other people might
hear that and be like what I don't get
it I totally get it I'm the same way I'm
absolutely the same way people who are
saying Sam's camera go in and out of
focus we're just we're working on the
new studio look we got to figure out
some settings so just yeah just have a
seizure today but by next episode you'll
be totally fine
um all right so let me give you one
while we're on this top well actually I
want to do two things
number one you've said The more plates
more dates guy a couple times now
um you know is that a dog whistle to try
to get him to come on maybe could be but
totally it is I love this guy man but
you also tweeted something out the other
day and I think he's a good example you
said something like the following you go
to have a great podcast you need
either like three factors and I think
you said
unique slash amazing content
uh unique slash amazing delivery and
then the last one is unique slash
amazing perspective so like you have
specific knowledge or insights that like
you know the average person doesn't have
and you said you need at least one to
have a successful podcast
um two is she was great three would be
unbelievable but extremely rare and you
got a bunch of replies to this
um and I would I want to first ask you
about I want to ask you a little bit
about that but also let's use this guy
Derek from more place more dates as a as
a as a case study here I think he's a
perfect example of what you're doing so
unique amazing content before him I
didn't see any YouTube channels I'm sure
there were some but they were nobody was
popular but there wasn't like a common
it wasn't a common content category to
be like I'm gonna make videos
speculating is this dude on steroids and
if so what roids do I think it is that's
his that's his entire promise of his
channel from a non-judgment perspective
this guy Derek says yeah here's what I
use he's not trying blood work he's not
trying to take them down he's just
trying to speak honestly about what he
thinks and he's like yeah there's my
here's my guess uh if I'm this dude I'm
like you're looking like this is what
I'm doing and you know here's the
evidence that I'm piecing together to
make that that claim and so you need
content check
unique delivery his delivery is actually
very very good it's very good because
it's non-judgmental because it's not
overproduced because he's not trying to
sell you something during the thing and
he's just like humorous on laughing
about it so he does it without like
there are other people that do this and
they're either judgmental or they're
like aha I'm ripping the mask off this
Scandal like I Expose and he's just like
he's like you know he'll like the guy
will claim he's all Natty like all right
sure bro like whatever you say right
like I don't think so and like that's
the level of like his delivery and then
he and he has a lot of really good
phrases like he'll be like oh this guy's
looking Saucy here yeah he's like it's
sauce to the gills he just wants to be a
little Saucy that's all right like he
just has really funny his delivery is
good I don't even care about I don't
have any interest in steroids I don't
even care if other people are taking
steroids I will watch his channel
because his delivery is so good he's so
likable like he's very like he watches
his channels like I would be friends
with him and it's actually
a self compliment it's a self-delusion
that you think he would be friends with
you because the guy's like just like he
just seems like a good dude a great hang
so I think that's the second one third
amazing perspective he has he has that
also because he actually has quite a bit
of scientific knowledge but also like
Street science so like he's not just
straight academic nor is he just a
meathead he's got enough knowledge about
the science while having enough you know
sort of Street smarts about what a
dude's actually use when they're doing
this stuff and how do they say it makes
them feel what do they say are the side
effects dude he's so good and you want
to know another interesting thing about
him is no one knows his last name so I
actually tried to like Google and I only
spent five minutes I'm sure I could
really find it but he's done a really
good job everyone just knows him as
Derek from more plates more dates and
you can't find a lot of info like
personal information about him
wow that's interesting I didn't know
that
um
and he records I think he records every
I think he makes a video every single
day so he makes a video every single day
and he's got 1.5 or 2 million
subscribers and it's really good and
what's really fascinating is that
there's guys like him who they don't
call themselves a journalists with a
capital J but they really are you know
these guys are doing investigative
journalism and it's quite good it's
better than a lot of different stuff out
there that's done by the quote
professionals yeah yeah totally
um so yeah he's great okay so that's a
good example
um should we can should we continue the
theme of uh by the way for that for that
podcast one that I quoted I I further I
said um I go let's do all in for an
example
uh their delivery it's decent I said
it's decent which I thought was like a
compliment but I was like their delivery
is is pretty decent they're not like a
comedian you know they're not like um
cereal or like some like investigation
especially well well produced and cut
and edited and or or like a unique
format that we haven't seen before it's
like you know four Dudes on a zoom call
yeah four guys on a zoom call sometimes
speaking through airpods and like
they're quite funny they're quite
charismatic but they're not like 10x
better at that than other people who are
I'd say it's definitely above average
like you know the intros they do the
kind of ball busting and like the way
yeah but that's not 10 times that's not
10 times better than the other people
of that magnitude I'm comparing them to
like the other like people who are doing
great yeah uh it's maybe better it's
maybe worse than a sum it may be better
than a lot uh and then what else did I
say I said their delivery was was decent
their content like the the format and
everything that's just normal it's just
four people who are speaking it it's
kind of rare that you have well they're
talking about current events which is
not like current events and news which
is not like um
super unique it's not a super content
angle right that in itself is not the
unique part but the thing that makes it
amazing is that it's them it's for
people who typically who are incredibly
like ungodly successful potentially some
of them are billionaires and they sit
down every week and they talk about all
types of stuff in an unfiltered way that
is 10 times better than most things that
are trying to become that and that's why
they're awesome and people including
Jason I I think Jason one of the hosts
he was like I think he's thought I was
insulting him uh and I'm like no dude
this is like this is a compliment I said
like it's it's like saying like LeBron
is like good at a lot like he's so such
a great basketball player but maybe he's
not the best at blocking shots or
whatever yeah and people got mad at me
and they're trying to pick a fight and
that was not my intention I I to me I
was complimenting them yeah yeah yeah I
thought you were complimenting them but
you have a way with words where you'll
like you'll add a little period after a
word you're like it's decent period and
that that kind of sounds like you know
like like this you gotta you gotta watch
the periods dude the periods totally
change the tone like if you're using a
period like it's [__] Twitter I have
like 190 characters
and you used one of them on a period and
you know that that thing that adds that
adds the tone right I did not mean it
that way I did not mean it that way
but you also doubled down after he was
like you know whatever he put that I
took that personally meme up there uh
you're like you know I said what I said
it's decent oh I didn't double down I I
don't backtrack I'm like dude yeah your
delivery is like pretty good you're not
like Theo vond you don't say like the
most like funny [__] on Earth you say
pretty great stuff
but whatever that's my point
Sam the kind of guy that doubles down on
a 17 in Vegas he's like whoa sir are you
sure I said what I said give me another
card
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better all right
so I have one that's not it's not in the
category we did SPF liar probably fraud
scammer whatever we did liver King liar
probably scammer probably allegedly
whatever
this is not that but I am calling this
The Curious Case of Katie Han
that's right music
what was that music that's my new that's
my new uh like X-Files Style music
whatever we're getting into a uh a
little case that makes me say hmm how
does this work so how do you spell This
Woman's name I want to Google her while
you're talking Katie like Katie is it
Katie and then Han h-a-u-n
um okay so she you know I think you
probably know of her
um seems like a great person so you know
uh
I think her her backstory is kind of
like uh you know went to Stanford law
um and then worked you know for worked
for the government so she I forgot what
her she was like Federal prosecutor or
something it was her job title
um let me find my notes here so
okay so she uh she goes to Stanford law
then she spends a decade as a federal
prosecutor uh for the the doj
um and she's you know and then she
creates at one time the government's
cryptocurrency task force and we know
her because she was involved with or
helped uh I think after the fact with
the Silk Road case so the Silk Road was
you know that website where people were
buying and selling drugs and you know
you could buy anything assassination
attempts you could buy a lot of crazy
[__] on there
um they eventually take Ross down in
your your neighborhood uh in San
Francisco and after the fact they you
know have all this Bitcoin from because
Silk Road was using Bitcoin for most of
the purchases and so she's involved in
that case that's kind of how she got on
my radar was she did a great interview
with Tim Ferriss where she's talking
about that story so you know I hear the
story that's kind of amazing like
um this person who like you know was
just grinding it out as part of the
government and that's kind of was the
impression I had of her was this like
awesome civil servant
so imagine the look on my face when I
hear that Katie Han just purchased a 41
million dollar home in Atherton
41 million dollar home what's going on
what's going on here Katie what are you
how much do you have to be worth 41. go
to doj average salary Federal prosecutor
94 000 to 150 000. okay so she worked
there for ten thousand years no okay
that's not it so what's what's been
going on so Katie's on at one point with
that doj seller she could pay her
property taxes for a month yeah The
Gardener is like yeah her property is
making that so
so but you know she made a switch so she
did the decade there and she's doing
these like I forgot what you call like
the RICO cases and it's like these crazy
like drug cases cartel stuff and then
she makes the leap and she comes all of
a sudden she's a VC so uh she becomes a
VC at Andreessen Horowitz in 2018 she
joins as a general partner
uh the year before that 2017 she was
named to the board of coinbase that's
interesting I guess like you know they
wanted a diverse board member who had a
different background coinbase no you
can't you can't say that she's a dive I
mean that's [__] you know what I'm
saying like her her work history so
she's not a business person she's from
like a regular the regulatory like you
know okay cool side of things that's her
expertise so that's a good person to
have on your board somebody who know who
was part of the government's
cryptocurrency task force definitely see
the value there
but how much value is what I gotta ask
that's the question of the day how much
value and what's this too much value
okay so she joins the board
and she gets uh so okay no on the day of
her IPO it was worth 73 million that was
April 14 2021 and
um she sold pretty much the top so she
was selling at uh
you know she was she was sold at that
that price and then she sold even more
as it went up to like whatever 300
something dollars a share uh it's
currently trading you know for far less
than that so let's see what coinbase is
trading at today coin stock price we've
got 40 something bucks a share yeah 41 a
share
whatever 300 380 you know 380 type of
range
so sells the absolute top but what I
have to the question I have and so I'm
not saying anything wrong or illegal
yeah more power to you what I don't
understand is
why did this person get a hundred
million dollars for sitting on the board
is that not an outrageous number so like
there I don't think there's any
wrongdoing
but God damn how did somebody make so
much for doing so little like a board
seat you know a board member does not
work very hard for the company a board
member does not usually create this much
value I thought board members typically
got like 250 000 a year like yeah that's
the normal board compensation so what I
want to know is why did this board
member get a hundred million dollars and
um I don't know if you know the answer
to this but that is the that is why it
is the Curious Case of Katie Han what
what well you're asking this question
you're asking this sounds like a leading
question it sounds like you have an
opinion but keep in mind I'm looking
just at earlier about these things she
founded a thing called Han Ventures
which is which has a 1.5 billion dollar
uh fund that's focused on web three and
I believe she's the only partner so the
fees on that alone two percent venture
capitalist gets two percent management
fees on is typical and her 1.5
billionaire fund and she's the only
partner I think that's 30 million
dollars per year
that she takes as her management fees
that's [__] crazy and when she was at
Andreessen uh again hard to know the
exact specifics here but like they're
the a16z crypto fund was seven billion
dollars I think at the time
um
there were five general Partners uh you
know so I don't I don't know exactly if
that if that number's the total after
coinbase is exit or if that's what they
raised I haven't gone that that far in
but like I think it's it is
believable that she was making 30
million dollars that she's made 30
million dollars plus off of her slice of
the Andreessen crypto fund before she
left
um
and by the way I think her portfolio
there coinbase was the only one that
that has exited there's are we there's
autograph there's Royal there's a bunch
of others but like these are these are
early early bets right because we're
only talking four years ago when she
joined the fund
um so kind of crazy that somebody made
100 100 million dollars plus off of uh
off of their board seat after working
for the government for 10 years
afterwards yeah and so I don't know
what's going on I don't know if this is
like a very fancy way of like buying
favor in uh in Washington it's like hey
we're going to get this veteran who's
super plugged in you know
great she gets this uh you know really
really really really really really
really really really Capital really
strong comp and
um you know she's gonna make sure that
the right people you know think
favorably about coinbase uh I don't know
if it's that I don't know if this is
standard I don't think this is standard
for what board members make yeah that's
crazy what did the other board members
what's going on there did you look at
the other board members
um the during the S1 you could see kind
of who the other major shareholders were
um I didn't see any of the other board
members that were there but I could I
could be wrong so there's Mark
Andreessen is there Fred Wilson those
are the investors
um
Maybe
yeah I mean hers is just outsized so
like uh I don't know who who's Goku
rajaram I think he's uh I think he might
have been another board member so let me
see coinbase I don't know if he worked
there if he's a board member
um
but he got you know whatever he had was
600 000 shares hers was 5.9 million uh
shares so like you know just simply like
a step a step higher yeah he was also a
board member so like for some reason
she got 10 times more in her stock Grant
than this this dude Gokul did
this is yeah this is wild things that
make you say
I don't I I agree this is a very curious
okay it could be a perfectly reasonable
accident for this I don't know it I
would love to hear it
um and I'm not I'm not owed any
explanation either I just thought this
was weird because I'm like how the heck
did this person who worked at the
government for almost their whole career
except for the last three years how are
they buying 40 million dollar pads that
doesn't make sense to me
um and then I looked at where the money
came from and then that didn't make
sense to me but again that might be my
own limitation of you know knowing how
this stuff works have you ever spoke to
her or like heard her speak
I've heard her speak yes she's um
she's you know whatever she tells cool
stories I I heard her on a couple of
podcasts I have she's invested she's
co-invested in some of the crypto deals
that I'm in so I'm not saying like yo
she's a bad investor if she is then I
probably I'm terrible uh so so you know
I don't know much about her from that
angle but there was one other funny
thing so there's this guy uh LeRon who
uh LeRon shapira I don't know if that's
I don't know if I say that right but
have you seen this guy on Twitter he's a
fan so he listens to the show he is also
the number one like crypto skeptic on
Twitter so his mission is basically to
just expose the like you know like the
fallacies scams and hypocritical things
about web3 and so he tweeted this out uh
four days ago he goes Open Seas a large
investor Katie Han claims that nfts have
many uses and invites us to check out
her latest purchase okay let's check it
goes to her profile on on Open Sea and
it's called wrapped Moon cat and it's
just like this purple like cat it's like
okay
um that not only has no uses uh you know
besides just being a funny little
purchase her account has zero activity
since June if you weren't using nfds
yourself maybe you shouldn't keep
investing in the space uh and you know
so he's kind of called her out of that
now of course she could have other
wallets or whatever but like it is a
little strange that you know the kind of
lead investors you know in in opency the
biggest you know nft platform doesn't
seem to have much activity
you know on the platform Beyond this
woman I've I've like do you like look at
Zillow and like read like The Real
Estate like trade magazines of like you
know anytime someone buys like a 50
million dollar home or 20 million dollar
home I love reading that stuff do you
ever read that stuff yes and actually
call to action I want to uh I want to to
know or help start uh one of these
Instagram accounts that's just featuring
baller homes that Ballers buy so like I
just want like celebrity business
celebrity kind of like just homes that
rich people are buying like who are they
how are they rich and what's their home
look like uh I think that'd just be a
great Instagram account that I want to
follow and I I don't know if that
exactly exists uh so so somebody start
that please and no I I love that stuff
and I always think about the economics
of that of like how do people afford the
I don't know 30 40 50 60 million dollar
homes I want to know what the monthly
nut is each month if they have a do you
have to have a full-time staff member
there's no mortgage right I don't that's
not a mortgage but you're not I don't
know what are you doing are you putting
like getting like a 40 million dollar
mortgage like I don't I don't know
that's why I want to know I want to know
I want to know what the tax bill is I
want to know how they actually care for
it I want to know what their liquid
position is and like how they finance it
if they pay cash like what they do uh
when you have a 40 million dollar home
is that like do you view it like for
example when I think of a home uh owning
a home I don't think of it as
necessarily an asset I think of it as
like a store value because they
typically don't grow much more than
inflation and so like do they view that
as like an asset do they take care of it
of like like an asset like I just want
to know how they how they account for it
in their in their net worth there's so
many fascinating things with owning
these 40 and 50 million dollar homes I
want to know all about how they work and
frankly I just want to have a huge I
don't know any of that [__] I just want
to have one
do you tip the landscape or do you not
tip him I was like dude who cares about
all these details man I wanna who bought
it how'd they get rich what does it look
like and how can I get one those are my
phone I'm about that too man I just I'm
always curious about how that works
because in in New York you see it like
crazy you see people buying 20 30
million dollar homes and there's you
know it's another shocking thing is how
many of them there are there's so many
of them I read this blog called Mansion
Global and they always talk about like
different mansions that are being bought
and sold in New York there's just so
many of them in San Francisco there's
not that many 20 30 40 million dollar
purchases in New York it's constant and
it's like a [__] condo it's crazy
yeah I think I told you this once but um
when I was working with Michael Birch he
put up his he he it's for sale right now
I think he put up his house in San
Francisco
and so uh for like three years right I
think I was at his house and he's like
yeah I was like you're gonna sell this
place and he's like yeah I'm gonna sell
it I was like so you bought this for
like 30 million dollars he's like yeah I
was like the highest purchase at that
time I think in San Francisco and he's
like I was like well I was like was that
I was like did you ever pray you're
gonna have to sell that you can take a
big loss on this or what he's like no I
don't think so uh and so and then when
he came on listed he listed for 50
million dollars which it didn't sell a
bit but
um but you know that's kind of like the
the range here and I was like how do you
even sell a house like this you know
like what's the process do you just put
it on the MLS like do you have open
houses on Sundays no it's a big problem
hand out flyers and so he was like no
actually this is a one of the ideas I
wanted to talk to you about like
I'm thinking like what if we made a
service for buying and selling these
like only homes that are worth 10
million or more he's like because it
breaks the traditional model like you
shouldn't pay six percent commissions to
an agent when the pr when the purchase
price is 20 million or 30 million
dollars is that how much they pay well
that's just like the standard real
estate model is that right is the five
or six percent and Michael goes and like
tries to negotiate and they're like ah
you know our paperwork already says six
percent like it's gonna be a hassle to
like change that six to one I'm gonna
have to hire somebody for the social
media and it's like yeah okay you know
like a month like what are you talking
about here I'm like it's like look I
didn't make up the rules I just thought
them up and wrote them down you know
like he wanted to make a thing that was
a service for only selling homes that
are 10 million or more it's a it's a
flat one percent commission that's it
because you could do one percent on a 20
million dollar home and it's it's pays
for the actual service that was done by
the person who's doing it he goes second
it's um
one broker not two so you have
um you know you're basically that you're
gonna take both sides he goes no open
houses because like people just want to
walk through my house they're not
serious buyers so basically anybody who
does the the open house tour there's
like on the website itself you'd be like
almost like an accredited investor it's
like you need to show that you are able
to buy homes of this caliber in order to
get access to the open houses I actually
toured Michael's home I was one of those
people I I saw that they were having
finger sandwiches
mud all I found your shoes yeah like oh
free sandwiches
when I got there I was gonna get bombed
up yeah a sandwich
I was like no ham
so so he's like you know that's wanting
to be one difference and then
um he's like you know the the or he's
like the the broker's Commission on top
of the one percent is just a tip based
on how you felt the service was like if
you felt like you were taking really
good care of then you can optionally tip
um and so he had like this whole plan
and he's like he's like figure out how
many of these houses sell here so I did
some analysis and I was like oh there's
you know I forgot it I was like seven or
eight years ago but it was thousands
yeah it was like there's like you know
five thousand or ten thousand homes like
this sold per year
um okay so you back that out average
home let's say is 15 million that's in
this category so that's X hundreds
millions of uh of it was like in the
hundreds of millions of sales you know
so then your one percent commission
would be X and um like okay how would
you take the market oh these are all
your friends okay that makes sense we
can get the first hundred hundred people
just out of your network that makes
sense uh we never pulled the trigger I
think we should have
um
because I thought it was a great idea in
fact I had a whole brainstorm with him
which is just like yo what are the one
percenter problems like tell me the the
like I got you know my problems sound
like I can't even speak about my
problems because they sound too
privileged because they exist and
nobody's talking about them and you know
them we could build for them and you
know all the people that are in that
group so you could like kind of help
bring those people on board of whatever
service we make so
um so yeah that that was I think a good
brainstorm in general dude I think
that's awesome I think uh I can't decide
if that would be a pain in the ass of
people to work with or if it would be
the best person to work with you know
like are they are they or are they not
going to nickel and dime you if no then
yeah it could be awesome
well I don't think it's necessarily
about nickel and diming but this is how
I feel about all businesses that are
based on influencers
um
it sucks doing an influencer based
business
because you are pretty much always
groveling at the feet of these people
who they should take your offer it's in
their best interest but they are just
busy and they have too many offers and
they don't care and even if they say yes
then they'll just flake on you even if
they say yes when it comes time to post
the thing it'll be done half done and
you're like oh my God this is like we
really needed this to work this was
really important to our business and
like you know it's so difficult to do
stuff like that of course when it works
it works right like you know you build
one of the you know you build the
whiskey brand with Conor McGregor or you
um you know you do the Honest Company
with Jessica Alba like you could make it
work for sure but I hate influencer
based businesses I remember
um I remember talking to a buddy who was
building something around twitch when we
were both in the twitch space and twitch
is basically like you know there's 100
streamers that matter and if you can get
them everybody else will follow if you
can't get them it's very hard to make
stuff work
and I go I'm like I'm like talking to
them over over dinner I'm like what
about this strategy what about this
strategy what about this pivot hey just
I'll never forget it because I heard
this and I ended up pivoting my business
because this just rang in my ears for so
long he goes I'm just tired of sucking
dick man
this person I didn't know
this was a friend this is for a business
meeting and it's and he said this to me
and I go what and I I asked him what and
then I immediately knew exactly what he
was talking about it's the thing I had
been doing for the last year which was
basically going and trying to get these
like 20 people who really really
mattered to just like watch our demo to
like just say yes to like just partner
with us or like just agree to take our
money to promote our thing
and I was like he's right I hate this I
really really hate this and we pivoted
like three months later because I was
like that's Hilary there's a terrible
style of business to build well thank
you Katie for bringing us to this topic
The Curious Case of Katie Han yeah uh do
I need to play the sound again no okay
dude you're gonna get DMS about this so
well I'm sure we're gonna have a
follow-up dude Andreessen already hates
me man they uh why do they hate you mark
blocked me again you blocked me first
for the clubhouse thread which by the
way
not only she did not have blocked me
where's my where's my apology I was
right I called that [__] that was a bad
investment it was gonna fail I called it
um okay so you know he blocked me then
that he unblocked me for some reason and
you know I got a second chance a second
lease on life why did he unblock you
just think about that through his head
like what was he going through his his
going through his what happened to be
like oh let's just someone sends someone
in The Firm sends the post the thread he
clicks it says you can't view this you
have blocked the person he's like
[__] all right I'm blocked this
person so yeah that's the only thing I
can imagine how I would even show back
up on his radio I don't know maybe just
laying in bed going through his blocks
be like oh I miss him the one that got
away yeah like I wonder what he's doing
yeah I wonder what he's up to now like
do you think we're staring at the same
moon right now he's looking at the 65
Indians who work for him and he's just I
just I just need one more I just wanted
more none of these are right none of
them are above six feet tall I want a
six foot tall one
so I don't know what happened but he
unblocked me and then the other day uh
he blocked me again I don't know I don't
know what I did I'm not even mentioning
this guy I think what I did was I I put
out that tweet that I said like you know
this year I've realized that like a lot
of the things I thought were smart money
and you could just kind of follow them
or just assume they know what's going on
like there is no smart money in the
space FTX everybody thought was the the
Quant Geniuses did you Quant genus
Traders and the [__] dummies and
scammers uh and then you know chamotho
Ben spax this is the IPO 2.0 oh this
must be great oh nops back collapse you
know these are all but you didn't
mention him lipstick on a pig I did
mention him oh I didn't see it you
specifically named him
no no I didn't name it Mark Andreessen I
just said a16z
whatever I wasn't trying to pick on
anybody I was just saying like the most
prestigious names
um also make a bunch of bets that don't
work out that's part of their business
model this is what I was trying to say
it's part of their business model you
can't look at any one bet in isolation
and say well if they did it it must be
it must be good it must be smart it must
like they must know something I don't
know in fact trust your own gut trust
your conviction trust your research
um because you know you don't know their
whole portfolio you don't know the
strategy and they're going to make
mistakes that's part of like Venture
investing so like you know don't just
assume because the really smart person
who you like to listen to
um invest in this that doesn't mean it's
a good investment necessarily do you
think that having like being an [__]
on the internet like I don't think you
and I are [__] but both of us
sometimes get into it without different
toes do you think that we dip our toes
yeah just a tip do you think that that
is gonna bite Us in the butt or that it
helps us or should we just go the nice
guy route like like I can think of a few
guys who are [__] and it's paid off
for them or not [__] but like like
Scott Galloway and Jason galcanus both
cause of fuss they get into it with
people and it's in I would say been in
that positive for them there's a few
other examples where I can just say it
just has ruined their reputation but do
you think and then there's other guys
who like Jason lemkin who did it
uh I don't know I mean there's people I
follow where I'm like oh you're just a
joke and not even I don't even want to
mention them because uh I just don't
want to do that but there's people who
because I can't think of them no I
definitely can I'll tell you all fair
but like you I I messaged you one the
other day or I'm like uh this person I
just it's it's they're working through
some stuff okay and anyway I just think
that uh like sometimes it hurts their
reputation but other times it's like
it's definitely been beneficial where
there's guys like you know who Jason
lemkit is I love Jason he's disaster
yeah he's great just generally a
positive person and I never said hear
him he goes out of his way not to
disrespect people another guy's Nathan
Barry goes out of his way in nine out of
ten times to not disrespect him not
disrespect people the one time he called
someone out which was gumroad I was like
oh well gumroad must be bad because
Nathan never is rude right do you think
that being rude has its benefits or are
you gonna try and be like a the nice guy
um both I think I think being a kind of
call-out artist has its benefits is very
addictive
um
you could be right you could be wrong it
kind of doesn't matter you're
provocative people pay attention to you
people will fight with you it definitely
draws attention so if your goal is
attention it definitely works
having said that
doesn't really generate a lot of
positive like positivity in your life
and doesn't add a lot of value typically
sure unless you go full on like a WWE
character which is what I consider like
Sky Galloway to be
um where they just you know hey I'm
going to take this super strong stance
I'm going to argue it and like if I'm
wrong like the truth kind of the truth
or accuracy is like sort of secondary I
wouldn't say it's not an important but
it's secondary like the more important
thing is to have like strong opinions I
get shared I get read they get commented
on that cause a debate because that's
the um
that's what makes uh that's what makes
that's what drives clicks that's drives
followers things like that so there's
strategically I see that Advantage life
you know like life EV I think it's kind
of net negative and um but I also don't
think you should just be like Mr Nice we
know a bunch of people that are like
this that will talk mad [__] and text
messages to us
but they won't then publicly they'll
stick up to those people and it's like
that that is disgusting to me that I
actually judged the worst I would rather
you know just speak my mind but
sometimes realize that like you know hey
I'm wrong uh you know more often than
I'm right and be like ah sometimes it's
just not worth the hassle like you just
don't you don't need to say anything at
all you could just kind of go on with
your day
um is there any time that you've been
rude to someone on the internet and
you've lost sleep over it
that's crazy to me that's crazy to me
that you do that you you feel bad you
feel guilty or something or what happens
yeah sometimes I'll say something to
someone I'm like oh man I I was too rude
I came off I'll question it like I'll
say ah that was maybe a bit much or like
uh you know I should have just stayed
out of it or whatever but I don't like I
guess loose sleep just sounds so serious
um like for example when I wrote that
club when I wrote that Clubhouse I
remember getting a message from
um
I won't say their name but somebody I I
respect I admire somebody super smart
and somebody who's kind of like you know
Loosely affiliated with that that you
know like the project so
um and they were like oh man this
Twitter thread like you know I'm torn on
one hand amazing storytelling and I
think you might be right
um on the other hand I don't really like
you know tearing down like a startup
like you know startups are you know
small fragile things like you know
I don't really like teardowns in general
we should be building each other up
um
but like you know this was a you know
whatever this was like it was super
interesting the way you wrote it and uh
and I was like yeah I think that's right
like I think that's a fair I think
that's a really fair point like you know
uh I have nothing against them I sound
like I wanted it I was not like I was
rooting for it to fail or anything like
that I just thought this is what might
happen based on my previous experience
in the space and I thought this how it
might play out and I just wrote it and I
just sent it and I thought oh you know
there's something to that you know I
don't really wanna
you know even though I know I could make
it my thing to be the teardown guy
I don't like where that leads me uh
right right that's a that's a coin I
don't want to Corner myself in that area
so you know what like
let's just uh what I'll often do is I'll
say I'll say it I'll say let me see how
that goes let me see how I feel about
that and maybe later I'll say uh you
know what I should have just stayed out
of it or I shouldn't have said that or
that was too harsh or whatever and uh
okay lesson learned but I just sort of
move on from it I don't really like you
know dwell on it it's like I'm okay
floating you know like it's a trial
balloon it's like let me just put that
out there I'll do this with ideas all
the time too I'll be like I want to do X
anybody want to work on this with me and
then people do I mean I'll be like ah
you know after I see how kind of like
the first three days went and I kind of
slept on the idea a little bit like no
I'm just not doing that and I think
people find that very strange and like
but for me I'm like this is like an
experimental platform like I'm not like
uh
I don't know it's not that serious uh
it's okay to like say something and
change your mind
you know further reflection or
information that's okay like when you
tweet it out that you're gonna put x
amount of your net worth into crypto and
then someone automatically wrote an
article about it and you're like
well you know like there's it's a
discussion
I did that one uh
especially think like uh this happens
all the time people could tell you when
they buy they don't usually tell you
when they sell
um and or they don't tell you if they
hold right like they don't tell you in
either direction so people make a whole
lot of assumptions about things uh like
you know somebody told me I remember
somebody told me this stock was great
and then like you know it turned out to
be dog [__] I was like oh man we we got
busted on that one he's like no I sold
but like at the top I was like dude
where was my message for that like you
know
you only told me to buy part
um
all right I think that was a that was a
lively discussion was that is that the
Potter you want to do one more uh no
that's the Pod let's I have a bunch of
other topics but yeah that's save them
for Monday we have a bunch of cool
people we have Austin Reef from morning
Brew coming on uh formerly my Nemesis
now one of my great friends he's gonna
come who are the cool people that are
coming on
[Laughter]
people don't know this by the way Austin
saw Hill these are our friends we we
make fun of each other all the time and
uh
you know it's just a it's just a
competition who can who can get the
right zing in on the other person uh at
the right time we have Austin do we have
anyone else interesting coming up
um the founder of whoop is coming on uh
we're gonna do another
um Millie early Awards where we do our
end of year Awards with Andrew Wilkinson
you know the three-year Tradition now
and uh I think that's that's kind of the
most popular episode of the year so so
that one's coming up and then early next
year we're having the return of dear
deck
I think Jonathan booked him we got in a
little bit early uh we're early on his
podcast journey I take a lot of pride in
that uh he's been on he was on impulsive
the other day and I watch all of them
man he's inspiring the guy's awesome
he's great it's the real deal all right
cool I'm looking forward to that all
right that's the pod
[Music]